être en me veut dire être sur terre
comme mortel c'est à dire habité habité
être mise en sûreté veut dire un rester
enclos dans ce qui nous est par an c'est
à dire dans ce qui est libre et qui
ménage toute chose dans son être
le trait fondamental de l'habitation est
ce ménagement il pénètre l'habitation
dans toute son étendue
cette étendue nous apparaît dès lors que
nous pensons à ceux ci que la condition
humaine réside dans l'habitation au sens
du séjour sur terre des mortels
mais sur terre
déjà veut dire sous le ciel l'un et
l'autre signifie en outre de murray
devant les divins et impliquent
appartenant à la communauté des autres
la terre et celle qui porte qui sert
elle fleurit et fructifie étendue comme
roche et comeau s'ouvrant comme plante
et comme animal
le ciel et la course arc et du soleil
le cheminement de la lune sous ses
divers aspects la translation brillante
des étoiles des saisons de l'année son
tournant la lumière et le déclin du jour
l'obscurité et la clarté de la nuit les
mortels
ce sont les hommes on les appelle mortel
parce qu'ils peuvent mourir mourir veut
dire être capable de la mort en tant que
la mort seul l'homme meurt il meurt
continuellement aussi longtemps qu'ils
séjournent sur terre sous le ciel devant
les divins les mortels habite alors
qu'ils accueillent le ciel comme ciel au
soleil et la lune il laisse le recours
aux astres leur route aux saisons de
l'année leurs bénédictions et leur
rigueur
ils ne font pas de la nuit le jour ni du
jour une course sans répit
est morte elle habite alors qu'il sauve
la terre sauver n'est pas seulement
arraché à un danger c'est proprement
libérer une chose la laisser revenir à
son être propre sauver la terre est plus
qu en tirer profit
à plus forte raison que les puiser qui
sauve la terre ne s'en rend pas m il ne
fait pas d'elle sa sujette
ce que l'on a sous sa garde doit être
mise à l'abri
mais où l'habitation préserver telle
lettre
comment les mortels accompli style
l'habitation au sens d'un tel
aménagement est morte ne le pourrai
jamais si l'habitation était qu un
séjour sur terre sous le ciel devant les
divins avec les mortels habiter au
contraire c'est toujours ces journées
déjà parmi les choses l'habitation comme
ménagement préserve le fond des choses
dans ce auprès de quoi les mortels
séjournent dans les choses
crignier un première toile
on
non
une chose que je trouve formidable les
gars fur et à mesure qu'on s'avance
c'est comme une coque à molus une con
qui se déroulent et on a besoin qu'on
pénètre à l'intérieur d'une vraie ville
sert que eu à la fois c'est un indice à
développement la fois temporel et un
développement dans l'espace
du fait même de l'accord de la
constitution classique du fait qu'elle
longe une autoroute doit elle ne peut
pas sortir elle affecte la forme d'une
ville close
c'est donc un labyrinthe apparemment
fermé dans l'intérieur seul compte ce
sont les reprises antérieures de la
ville qui sont la partie habitée
ceci paraît date comme les critères ou
les cailles d'un animal
wen a quelque chose d'un coquillage à
quelque chose
il ne semble être à l'abri
suri le plus rassurant pour les années
c'est pour cela que cette ville à cette
forme que cette forme même étranger un
peu circulaire nous semble être le
l'enveloppent la plus propre à bruille
habilité à permettre d'éviter une ville
ne doit être quelque chose de complexe
d'un finit de peu compréhensible
d'infini dans le sens qu'on ne le
comprend pas conforme pas dans une vie
de waele fini et comment elle s'avance
d'habitude de l'urbanisme contemporain
est un élément tellement simple que
jamais il ne pourra être assimilée à une
véritable existence
du
il faudrait que ce soir d'une ville
aléatoire
nous tous soient surprise et comme le
temps d'habitude fait levin avec des
éléments dont on ne comprend plus la
raison
s'agirait de prouver quelque chose qui
soit comme le fruit un peu mûri du
hasard une ville du havre dans la sarthe
concertée secrètement mais dont
apparemment ne voit pas les systèmes
nous parlons de l'homme et de l'espace
ce qui sonne comme si l'homme se
trouvait d'un côté l'espace de l'autre
mais l'espace n'est pas pour l'homme un
vis-à-vis
il n'est ni un objet extérieur ni une
expérience intérieure il n'y a pas les
hommes
et en plus de l'espace car si jeudi un
homme et que par ce mot je pense un être
qui est manière humaine c'est-à-dire qui
habite alors en dix ans un homme je
désigne déjà le séjour auprès des choses
alors même que notre comportement nous
met en rapport avec des choses qui ne
sont pas sous notre main nous séjournons
auprès des choses elle-même
m
mais je
nous ne représentons pas comment
l'enseigne les choses lointaine d'une
façon purement intérieure de sorte que
tenant lieu de ces choses ce serait
seulement des représentations dell qui
défileraient au dedans le nous aidons
notre tête
les mortels sont cela veut dire
habitants ils se tiennent d'un bout à
l'autre des espaces